[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka citizen bane and
this video we're breaking down
everything you need to know about the
new netflix movie mank and its ending
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to check it out
yet then i highly recommend that you
turn off now
please subscribe to the channel as we do
videos like this every day
and also hit the thumbs up button if you
enjoy it without
the way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into the breakdown
okay so mank is directed by david
fincher
and it stars gary oldman as herman
mankowicz
the movie chronicles his life and
journey as he comes up with the
screenplay for orson welles citizen kane
and the figures that influenced it that
film is regarded as one of the best
movies ever made
and i remember that i bought it on
blu-ray but the transfer was so bad that
i took it back to the shop
i exchanged it for insidious 2 and i'll
never forget the shop assistant sighing
and saying that i was what was wrong
with society
well i'm a big film reviewer now helping
to make the world even worse
you sucker now citizencade is very much
a movie that is
often said should never be remade but
in some ways mank is sort of a remake of
it
now they didn't want to annoy people who
hold the original very dearly
and i'm one of them but the piece shares
several similarities
and is even shot to echo its style and
tone
mank also has credits appearing before
the picture similar to the movies of old
and it chronicles a man stung by his
demons as he tries to create a legacy
that people will look fondly upon
the movie jumps backwards and forwards
through time to chronicle the key
aspects of his character
so that we can better understand him
mank is told to tell the story he knows
which of course alludes to those around
him and in some ways himself
now they do actually say you can't
capture a man's entire life in two hours
and the best thing that you can do is
leave an impression
this feels very true of mank and though
we don't get the ins and outs of his
entire life
you can get an impression of how he was
in reality
this matter aspect and self-awareness of
the film is denoted in its typing of
time
which very much appears like a script we
opened in 1940
with hermann being taken to a cabin to
recover after breaking his leg in a car
accident
mank was promised 90 days to write the
piece but
similar to real life orson welles cut
this down to 60.
now in reality the studio weren't too
keen on all the issues that we see
happening in the film
but orson insisted that mank be its
writer and from this position
he dictated things it's pretty crazy to
think that orson welles directed and
starred in kane at 24
and mank also chronicles its impact and
how it changed the landscape of film
if you've seen the movie for yourself
you'll know that it was way ahead of its
time
and its editing style shot composition
and
general aesthetic makes it stand out in
comparison to other films released
around the era
now i think one of the biggest faults in
mank is that if you don't know citizen
kane that well
then a lot of the context information
and
key players will be lost on you i view
this movie
very much as something that shouldn't
really be viewed on its own
as you probably won't get all the
intricacies of it
in case you don't know kane was actually
based upon william randolph hurst
who in the film is played by charles
dance
much like kane hearst was a businessman
newspaper publisher and politician
that helped to develop one of america's
biggest media companies
he was an extremely powerful man and was
used to getting his own way
similar to wells thus when wells made a
picture that was pretty much a retelling
of his life
along with all the scandal in it the
pair came to blows
there's actually a documentary called
the battle for citizen kane that
chronicles their showdown
and it showcases how hearst tried to get
wells blacklisted in hollywood
hearst didn't want any of the less
respectable things he'd done
potentially brought to light and we very
much get the idea that mank in some ways
is hunting for a story
that could lead to his career getting
into a lot of trouble
the sled was based upon a bike that
hurst had stolen from him
and the word rosebud was the name given
to him
his his lovers ladybits at the time
sorry
youtube demonetization has me a bit
worried there now speaking of lovers
we meet marion davies an actress who was
very close to hearst
hurst and davies began a relationship
when she was a teenager
and this was scandalous for a number of
reasons firstly
there was the large age gap between the
pair and hearst's wife also refused
to divorce him which meant that they
were held in limbo
davies actually long to marry hearst but
his wife would not allow this to happen
on top of this the pair also had a child
together called patricia lake
lake was born in the early 1920s and
this conception was out of wedlock
so a lot of issues arose from it because
of the backlash that they faced
lake in her relationship to the pair was
always denied
and it was said that she was simply
davey's niece however on her death bed
in 1993
lake asked her son to publicly announce
that she was in fact the daughter of
both davies and hearst
turns out that lake was given to davy's
sister rose whose own child childhood
died in infancy
and they passed her off as theirs hurst
and davies apparently paid for all her
education
and spent a lot of time with her but
they never actually acknowledged her as
their own
and actually said numerous times to the
public that their parenthood was nothing
more than a rumor
when lake was 11 she learned the truth
and on her wedding day both hurst and
davies gave her away
however things were still kept out of
the spotlight
i think stories like this are so
interesting and engaging
and in my opinion the movie really could
have been boosted by focusing on them
instead of let's say it's slower aspects
now the film deals with the lack of
money in hollywood a monk trying to get
the script finished
under the pressing deadlines he faces
like kane the mystery of the movie
revolves around a key plot device and
that is
why did hearst write this script that
was so scathing to two people
that we see him moving in social circles
with many people suspect that mank is
out to get hurst because he was cut from
the payroll at the studio
and though our protagonist believes that
he's washed up we know kane is the best
thing he's ever written
it all comes to a head at a dinner party
in which the drunk monk
goes off the deep end apparently fincher
made them film this scene over 100 times
and showcases mang really berating
hearst for what he truly sees him as
and the faults in his character now i'll
get into that more in just a bit
but we also see as he tackles with
propaganda and the moral implications
that come with lying to the public
in order to achieve certain things for
political parties
mank even says that if you keep telling
a lie long enough
and loud enough that enough people will
eventually believe it to be true
it's a bit on the nose for our current
times but with a story that's almost
over 100 years old
i appreciate that they tried to work it
into being relevant
the propaganda that mgm put out forces
mank's friend
shelly metcalf to have a crisis and he
ends his own life over the whole affair
and is parkinson's diagnosis it adds
some real weight to the movie
and also hints to us why mank chooses to
do what he did
now to me man caesar's taking down of
hearst as a way to right the wrongs of
the studio
and that if he writes the project then
it will show the world the truth
to the backdrop of don quixote he
narrates hurst's actions in the 1934
election
which he views as making things worse
for the majority
this prototype script of citizen kane
combines the classic tale
along with william's choices and truly
shows us
why his opinions form the structure of
the film
hirsch doesn't really flip out over this
and instead he tells them the story of
the organ grinders monkey
this parable tells of someone doing what
a powerful person wants them to
and though they seem like they have
power in some respects they actually
don't have any they are simply operating
under the command of a higher up
and in the end are completely disposable
in the story the monkey believes that
it must be powerful and that the person
who actually controls it is the poor one
and this very much represents the
relationship between monk and hearst
though we have been told that hurst
thinks very highly of him
we realize this isn't the case and that
to him mank is somewhat of a court
jester
there to keep him entertained thus mank
wants to get back at him however he can
i think he used this very much as a way
to right the wrongs of the election loss
which the company he helped build was of
course responsible for
in the end he completes his masterpiece
but is relieved of the rewrites by rko
who want him to walk away from the
production mank wants credit though
and this causes orson to have so many
issues that
he almost has a breakdown he offers mank
ten thousand dollars to give him sole
credit for the picture
but mank fights this refusing to simply
be a monkey
or a monkey which yes i did have to get
one terrible pun in
didn't now as we know kane would go on
to become one of the most highly
esteemed movies of all time
but mank has very much been brushed to
the side with wells becoming the main
name that people bring up when
discussing it
it won the oscar for best screenplay and
the award was shared between mankind
wells
who also took credit for the picture
this has long been a source of
controversy over who wrote what
and over the decades there has been
several debates about the truth of it
in a letter to his father after the
release mank was furious that wells even
took any credit
as he said there isn't a single line in
the film that he didn't come up with
mang also refused to attend the ceremony
as he thought there was no chance that
he would win
and it's clear that wells didn't think
too highly of the awards either
sadly mank died of uranic poisoning and
this was brought on by his years of
alcoholism
after his death wells said he saw
everything with clarity
no matter how odd or how right or how
marvelous his point of view was
it was always diamond white nothing
muzzy
though he may not have been on the best
of terms with the figure in the end
i think it's safe to say that he
certainly left an impression and
hopefully
this video has given you one of the
people in the film
their legacy obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts on the movie so make sure
you comment below and let me know
if you enjoy this breakdown then please
drop a thumbs up and make sure you check
out our full video on the latest episode
of the mandalorian which is going to be
linked at the end
don't forget we're giving away three
copies of the lord of the rings 4k box
set
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of december so make sure you
get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can order some chatters on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time take care
[Music]
peace
[Music]
so
you